foreign
s us up next in Sioux City Matt welcome
to the show
hey thanks guys how are you both doing
today we are doing great how can we help
hey um real quick
um just intro I am 27 my wife's 27 we
have a year and two months old little
girl and uh my question for the day is I
just feel really davish as of today I
don't know why it hit me so hard today
um but like my baby steps are kind of
all over the place I've got fifteen
thousand dollars left in my student
loans I went to pharmacy school
graduated a couple years ago been
putting five thousand dollars towards it
ever since I graduated each month
um but we have the 15 000 in uh a
savings account and we kind of did that
baby step obviously backwards where we
saved three to six months and that's
just been a comfortable thing to do we
said first we're gonna do it when we
were having our daughter but we've kind
of kept with that another thing too is
like with our
um way that we do checking our savings
or just seeing how we do our payments we
kind of to do it retrospective instead
of actually doing like how you guys have
every dollar out like we know what's
going out but after a month has happened
we're not really you know fine-tuning
and figuring out each you know each day
kind of what we've been spending and how
we can improve on that I guess so I was
just looking for some inspiration if you
guys had some
um I Heard the Last Call there were some
a little bit of not like he wanted to
get yelled at and I kind of don't know
if I'm at that stage too actually can I
tell you can I tell you what it sounds
like
um yeah you sound exhausted
yeah a little bit today was a little bit
of a little bit of an exhausting day
which kind of got to this point I feel
like how much student loan most of the
pharmacy students I know graduate with a
a lot of debt how much did you graduate
with
uh 80 to 85. okay that's actually not
bad that's about a quarter of what it
usually is
um yeah you sound tired man and I am
here's you I want to free you if you
don't want to follow this plan
you still be a good guy still be a good
dad still be a good husband go about
your life man
if you want to do this go all in because
you're torturing yourself in the middle
yeah
millions and millions it's not it's not
it's not hard
just gotta make choice
you can be debt-free today is that what
you're saying you'd wipe out you'd wipe
yourself out but you could be debt-free
today
yeah I could yeah why like what what is
the security blanket
um yeah that I that I can't explain well
the way the way I explained it the first
time was we had a kid coming and I
remember hearing a few times from you
know just listening to you guys that was
one where it was okay to save um we have
some older vehicles but they're working
great I love them I got a 04 Grand Am
that I drove since high school and that
thing's still amazing got 03 Ford Taurus
um I don't know they're running great so
that's kind of something or if we need
to upgrade another kid potentially my
wife and I are trying to
um have another kid I don't know I guess
the unknown
um and I know that it's going to be paid
off like I said I've been doing 5 000
each month just be done man three months
from now just be done well just be done
you are choosing to hang on to a
variable and as a scientist you know the
goal is to reduce the variables get it
out of the out of the picture and then
be really uncomfortable what's your
take-home salary household wise
so my wife and I this is another problem
too so I'm just being shared up with you
guys it's we get about a hundred
thousand dollars after we get retirement
out of their
um so we're taking out retirement too at
this time too oh you're investing
yeah
correct well you can continue doing that
if you pay off the debt today and also
you need to get your emergency fund back
in order so you probably need to pause
for a few months but one of the reasons
you're exhausted is because you're
running 14 different directions and
wondering why you're not getting
anywhere and then you hate yourself
every time you take another step you're
like I shouldn't have taken that step
I'll run over here and then I hate that
guy we can't sit here and inspire you to
Greatness and motivate you what we can
do is help you build a habit and build
discipline to where you're just the kind
of guy who budgets and pays cash for
things and who has a vision for his
future and that Vision doesn't include
paying a lender every month
so that's what we can help you do is
create a vision and help you get those
values in place versus inspiring you
with an amazing sentence like never
heard it before where you go all right
I'm all in man we can't do that in seven
minutes
no but we can pull the rubber band back
and cause you to feel that pain what's
been inspiring about
go ahead George I'm sorry no it's all
good
what's been inspiring I was just gonna
say what's been inspiring is like
listening to your like George here and
you paying off your house like I that's
like been one that stuck with me for a
long time
um and that's what I'm excited to do I
want to get this debt done and I next up
to that is
hold on you don't want to you want to
want to no I want to you don't want to
because if you did you'd be debt free
you'd be debt free already yeah
something is keeping you from doing it
so make the choice man
yeah here's the thing though you're
right most people don't realize that
they are already in the ring they think
they can avoid the fight that is being
an adult
and what happens is you are just saying
like I don't want to fight and the world
just starts throwing punches at you
at some point you either tap out which
is fine I quit cool or you have to swing
back
and you're trying to pretend like you're
not in a fight and you are
you could be debt-free today the wants
you have the inspiration the George
inspired me dude by the way
um like so I get that I get where your
heart's at he's got to choose
yeah one of the best things we did is to
decide that our plan wasn't working and
that's a really hard pill to swallow
because you got to swallow your pride
and go dang it I thought I could
outsmart the system and so when we
decided to do this plan we just decided
it was we pre-decided that we were going
to go all in on this plan that Davis
wasn't going to get us to where we
wanted to go fast enough and when you go
all in and your wife is on the plan too
which means we got to get to the root of
maybe that security gland that was going
hey we really need an emergency fund
before we start paying off this debt and
we really should be investing because
that's a wise thing to do those things
are all great but the problem is when
you do them all at once you don't feel
the progress
and so the great news is you can make a
different decision today right now
yep and it's scary you're right but you
have to choose do you do you want to be
comfortable because that's what you
mentioned well just more comfortable to
have the emergency fund wow we owe under
15 000 Comfort to me is freedom and the
way you do that is by not owing anyone
anything and you have a great income we
can pause investing you're gonna get the
emergency fund way faster in place if we
stop the investing and stop messing
around which is going to create a real
sense of security because right now you
have a false sense of it and you're 27
and for whatever it's worth George and I
always say like sometimes the best
advice we can give you is this is what
we did in our house there's been several
times in my adult life my wife and I
have paused investing to meet a
financial goal for a short period of
time couple years here six months here
and so I'm just telling you what I do in
my own house to get ahead
and you're you're way younger than me
man
yeah
I mean I like I said that that was
enough though what you guys said too I
sometimes you just gotta need to hear
from people that have done it and I know
I know you guys have done it I've
listened enough to you guys but it you
know I it's it's something that I don't
know what it is it's maybe something for
you John to talk about more further if
you guys want to but Davis missed just
regarding even money and stuff too like
my faith I'm sometimes Davis I just feel
like maybe I'm hard on myself for being
Davis in many aspects of life but that
shouldn't stop me from actually doing
what I need to do you know well at some
point if you start to see some recurring
patterns in your life that are
disruptive
do the most the boldest bravest thing
you can do and go talk to somebody
yeah I've done that when I when the
color in the world starts to turn down
on me
and
um I reach out and I either have a group
of friends group of men in my life that
I trust I'm like dude I I'm starting to
slide and they'll say hey we'll come
over we're grabbing dinner we're going
out tonight to hang out or I could see a
therapist man I've got a coach that I
work with once a week like I have to
surround myself with other people that
say Hey it feels like the color's
draining out of your life it's not look
how bright that is there's Beauty over
here there's joy over here and by the
way go work out go exercise get this
crap paid off and so it's both in right
but go call somebody man you know what
to do man now the decision is yours are
you gonna do it or do you want to
continue living the way you've been
living either way we're cheering you on
this is the Ramsay show